eine große bitte ist lasst die kommunen
diesmal nicht alleine wir haben enorme
fluchtbewegungen auch wenn jetzt noch
von 100000 oder über eine million in die
unmittelbaren nachbarstaaten der ukraine
überführung sind haben in deutschland
schon etwa
115.000 flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
aufgenommen und es werden täglich mehr
die registrierung die erteilung eines
affen tanzen
da geht es um die anwendung der
massenzustrom schlechthin der
europäischen union und beschloss ich
jemand auf nicki heißt tatsächlich so
das ist die eine seite aber die
unterbringung vor ort die sicherung des
lebensunterhaltes wenn die medizinische
versorgung die erfüllung der
schulpflicht bei den kindern ist eine
mammut aufgabe für die kommunen aber es
ist eine gesamtstaatliche aufgabe und
hier dürfen wir die kommunen nicht über
gebühr belasten und muss rasch klarheit
herrschen beim bund und bei den ländern
wohnen an diesen an dieser stelle
geäußert werden kann und ein herzliches
dankeschön für das überragende
gesellschaftliche engagement bei der
aufnahme der flüchtlinge ist die not am
brot und größten kommen die besten
eigenschaften von den menschen zum
vorschein
ja ich bewundere ein bisschen wie ruhig
und sachlich und natürlich hat völlig
recht wolfgang bosbachs vorträgt wenn
man sich daran erinnert dass damals uns
erzählt worden ist dort kämen frauen und
kinder aus den kriegsgebieten den
wahrheit kamen 90 prozent junge männer
und zwar nicht nur aus den
kriegsgebieten wenn wir damals
kommentiert haben wir brauchen jetzt die
empathie der menschen und die
solidarität und wenn in den wirklichen
krisen wirklich betroffene kommen dann
sind die kapazitäten ab das ist alles
eingetreten und man muss jetzt
tatsächlich sehen dass diejenigen die
migration immer als eine art
heiligenschein als eine art
glücksbringer für die gesellschaft
gefeiert haben nehmen sie claudia roth
nehmen wir die
migrations euphoriker von der spd die
sitzen jetzt da in verantwortlichen
ämtern in der bundesregierung vor geht
hier in berlin
und die organisation schleift das also
man wirklich nur
fassungslos dabei stehen kann da gibt es
radio aufrufe dass man sich familien aus
der ukraine am bahnhof abholen kann wenn
man sie beherbergen will es gibt erste
fälle wo in hamburg familien wieder
zurückgegeben worden also mal
mitbekommen hat das ist kein geld dafür
gibt das ist haarsträubend man muss
registrieren man muss kontrollieren wir
haben drittstaatler darunter von denen
nicht ganz klar ist ob sie nicht zu
hause eigentlich schutz suchen müssten
wir müssen die kinder betreuen wir
müssen natürlich wissen wo wer ist wo es
geld braucht wo kinderbetreuung wichtig
ist wo es auch psychologische betreuung
braucht wenn man aus dem kriegsgebiet
braucht dafür muss man registrierungen
haben und zwar ein sehr ein
geschlossenes system ich habe mit
pfarrer siggelkow gesprochen in dem
gründer der arche der sagte es ist
diesmal schlimmer als 20 15 und das kann
eigentlich nicht sein deutschland ist
ein hoch industrialisiertes land mit
einem riesigen verwaltung das muss
funktionieren wenn man sich anguckt wie
bravourös polen das leistet jeder der
dort ankommt bekommt das angebot eine
sim karte mit mit einem guthaben darauf
zu bekommen natürlich gegen
registrierung er wird registriert wenn
er einreist er wird registriert wenn er
in eine aufnahme kommt und wenn er dort
wieder die verlässt würde auch
registriert alles völlig unproblematisch
führt dazu dass man einen hohen
logistischen
sachverstand dort einsetzt der in
deutschland nicht erkennbar ist und die
bundesregierung hat nach wie vor keinen
plan und noch nicht mal ein
krisenzentrum das kann so nicht sein
weil ich war gerade so ein bisschen
überrascht weil ich komme gerade vom
berliner hauptbahnhof und das ist ja ich
meine wir werden jetzt in den letzten
tagen als berliner da gewesen sein und
das ist ja wirklich unglaublich was da
an hilfe organisiert ist da steht zum
beispiel eine riesen truck von einem
privaten telefonanbieter denn diese sim
karten dann erwähnt hast auch hier aus
gibt aber das sind private initiativen
von menschen die da sind oder sind
private hilfsorganisationen rotes kreuz
von steiger stiftung viele andere machen
ja damit helfen ihnen auch vor ort oder
menschen sind ja sehr früh eben an den
bahnhof gegangen hier in berlin und
menschen mit mit karten und pappkarten
abzuholen zu sagen ob ein zimmer frei
man kann froh sein als ich das der große
flüchtlings track 2015 in münchen ankam
und nicht in berlin denn da war deswegen
ist es auch seht hier verstehe ich auch
nicht warm an vorbereitete hier ist das
totale chaos ausgebrochen
man kann nur hoffen dass herr bosbach
gehört findet das natürlich staatliche
stellen hier aktiv werden und diesen
track der eher noch zunehmen wird wir
werden ja noch weitere hunderttausende
wahrscheinlich bekommen flüchtlinge hier
irgendwo dann auch tatsächlich gesteuert
wird ich habe nur gehört dass in
hannover bei hannover ja ein
verteilungszentrum ist also da scheint
etwas zu funktionieren aber hier in
berlin ist hier wirklich eine große
krise ausgebrochen
ein punkt über den man nicht reden darf
aber wie wir vielleicht wir sind ja ein
offenes grimm wir trotz man reden sollte
ist dass es natürlich vielleicht auch
von der integration der menschen wenn
sie denn was hier viele annehmen nicht
zurück gehen sofern die zustände ist
irgendwann mal vor ihr zu lassen
wenn das diese integration
wahrscheinlich leichter werden wird 2015
bei sie uns kulturell das muss man
einfach sagen näher sind als all die die
2015 zu uns gestoßen sind wenn auch aus
bürgerkriegs gründen
in viele ort herr bosbach weil man jetzt
ja auch bilder an dazu auch mit blick
auf 2015 haben wir beziehungsweise
natürlich auch die politik vergessen
unsere hausaufgaben zu machen hätte man
jetzt besser vorbereitet sein müssen
wir waren darum geht es ja im ersten
wochenende september
überrascht wir können jetzt nicht
überrascht sein weil ja die entwicklung
in der ukraine vielleicht nicht im
detail aber doch in ihren auswirkungen
absehbar war und machen wir uns bitte
nichts vorher schüler auch das gehört zu
der wahrheit mann konnte erst über die
probleme die diese migrationsströme mit
sich gebracht haben offen reden nach der
kölner silvesternacht gehen und ich weiß
ich weiß dass die bundesregierung die
schließung der balkanroute kritisiert
hat aber doch froh war dass die
balkanroute tatsächlich geschlossen
wurde weil danach auch durch das
abkommen mit der türkei die zahlen
erprobt und deutlich zurückgegangen sind
im moment können wir das nicht
feststellen die zahlen werden eher
steigen und ich ahne was kommt der bund
wird erklären wir sind für die
registrierung zuständig das macht das
dampfen vorläufigen aufenthaltstitel
schutzstatus wahrscheinlich subsidiärer
schutz die länder werden sagen die
unterbringung muss aber bei den bei den
kommunen erfolgen das geht nur vor ort
das gar nicht in den landeshauptstädten
geregelt wird dass genau das was die
leute in unserem land nicht hören wollen
deswegen bildet bitte einen krisenstab
was für kone möglich ist das muss auch
für die flüchtlinge möglich sein wo bund
länder und gemeinden gemeinsam an einem
tisch sitzen die verteilung nach dem
berühmten königssteiner schlüssel ja die
ist schnell getroffen aber die
verteilung ist doch erst der anfang
aller bemühungen vor ort das können
unsere kommunen nicht alleine stemmen da
brauchen sie hilfe des bundes unter
ländern